good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast yeah it's tuesday hope
everyone had a great monday not as good
as mine because i rose groaned and got
annihilated on twitter by the miley
cyrus dance just a regular day for me
here at the morning too
yeah things they got crazy yesterday
they came for the comment section they
came for the dms i even got a little
uh debris what did they say about you
they said something
they also i just want to say the miley
stands are like really violent
i know sometimes violence is the answer
that's what someone's doing that means
that's actually really funny they were
being funny honestly i didn't mind you
like they're protecting their girl i
respect it we're all entitled to our
opinions
but i just have to say the overwhelming
amount of people that call me fat was so
i kind of missed that
no because people have been calling me
so much worse in the past couple years
they like forgot i was fat
so i was just so happy because it's like
so obvious it's really surprising that
the miley stands like on their moral
high ground or fat phobic and resort to
violence this is what
this is a dm i received your podcast
[ __ ] sucks by the way
i'd flatten that ugly mud of yours if i
ever saw it in the street
so don't mention my league wait i also
screamed
i also screenshotted some that's so
funny they were being so insane i like
lived for it okay
they were mostly directed at you because
i rewatched a segment and i really
didn't say much no it was about miley
cuz you were just
here's one ugly white [ __ ] instead of
criticizing the wonderful miley cyrus
you should be worrying about losing
weight
fat fix that double chin before speaking
out against a legend
someone else hoe and fat someone else no
talent
ugly fat [ __ ] um miley cyrus is a
legend and you
a fat no i was kind of living for it
smizers we see you i respect the hustle
and the clear um
surplus of time that you have on your
hands so crazy is that if my life had
gone in just like
a different direction i don't know at
what point i veered off this track but
like
i would have been one of those smizers
dming you know i know like remember when
you
literally like weren't in top shop and
you saw miley cyrus and like your
whole world came crashing down i was the
number one smizer of all time
i don't know of a bigger miley fan than
me like back in the day so
i guess if i could continue down that
path like i would be
be dming people like calling them a fat
a fat maybe um but instead i'm here
that's good and i think this is where
i'd rather be life just you know
is constantly throwing tangents and
fears and
i'm also disappointed in the miley
stands because when the bts stands came
for us like they gave us so much
irrelevant uglies like
the bts stands came for us and you know
what i kind of wish they came back for
us because
they don't even know how full circle
we've come like we were trashing bts
because they thought they should be
nominated for a grammy and i thought
they were insane
but now after dynamite like i fully
agree like
that is a grammy-worthy song and it
seems like the grammys are going out of
their way to like not even acknowledge
bts's existence and
now i understand why the bts stands like
are upset about that and also
upset at us for perpetuating propagating
that narrative 100 so actually i would
really love to hear back from the bts
fans letting them know like we've
changed and you were right
um but i'm gonna stand my ground on what
i said about miley but i do want the
smizers to know like i'm a huge miley
fan as well
um you can keep calling me fat that's
totally fine because you're not like 100
wrong and we see each other and you know
maybe we will meet again
and we can agree maybe we'll meet again
the next time miley's on snl so just
like a few weeks yeah
no that was like a fun little treat i
was so busy yesterday booked and busy
like back to being
back to back to back it was just so
crazy we recorded the redheads last
night
really hysterically funny episode like
the book is really cute and good but
there's not like that much
substance to dissect so we were just
like off the rails it was hysterical
new episode drops on thursday and you
don't want to miss it oh and it's never
too late to become a redhead it's time
i know you might think that it is no i
just said like we've done 17 episodes so
many books
but you can jump right in at any time
only 17 episodes
i think that this was our 18th we do one
of it a year
it's been oh wait a year dumbest thing i
ever said i was thinking weeks i'm like
52 weeks you've only done 17.
no one for more than a year it's been
more than a year and there was two
months where we did bi-weekly episodes
oh right okay wow that's crazy crazy but
it's still it's never too late to join i
announced
my pick for the next redheads i was
going to do a classic but i made the
decision to just take you on the journey
that i'm on
and i just chose the next book that was
on my want to read list like
which was oh should i give everyone it
hasn't come out yet because episodes oh
no sorry i forgot the episode i don't
know i kind of like want to give it away
because it's also exclusive
people like lost a week of reading
because we push it back and that's not
fair for me to do to you
tell them so we are reading the american
duchess
the story of consuelo vanderbilt by you
told me about this one
karen harper i love that yeah so
sneak peek the anderson cooper of it all
yes how is anderson cooper related to
consuela that we shall find out like
okay consuela's
relation to glory to gloria right yeah i
think one of the craziest like fun facts
about pop culture that i think a lot of
people forget about is that anderson
cooper is a vanderbilt
yeah it's kind of crazy i forget all the
time forgot again i forget all the time
i actually forget all the time how like
most people in hollywood are there by
nepotism and i'm actually i'm not one of
those people who like despises nepotism
like as someone
who like has a lot of sisters like if i
got like a movie job i would give them a
role as well
but you just forget that like everyone
is someone something i was thinking last
night
i had literally forgotten i forget who
it was that this person was like
someone's daughter and i'm like wow
really everyone in hollywood is just
like a big
incest i wonder who you were thinking of
i know i couldn't remember
whatever but that was like when that
article came out about girls
how like people didn't realize the four
characters on girls like every single
one of their parents was like a famous
artist or writer
or something that ultimately led to them
being on that show yeah it's just kind
of crazy
that is really crazy and my life is kind
of crazy
what's that from i don't know um
and my life is kind of oh hot it's a
tick tock sound well i
literally spent so much time on tic tac
hi i'm ryan
and my life is kinda crazy i remember
that you do
i cause that sound is from like that
show
oh right oh no when like two people like
look like each other and then
yeah yeah so i did the trend when vinnie
and um snooki had a baby that was me
oh cool whose baby are you jessica
chastain
and um ron from
and who's maybe are you mean and meaner
no i just said snooki and jay wow
no just calling your mom jessica
chastain like how nice am i
ron weasley really is that where you're
going with it oh sorry okay prince harry
is that better
no no no wrong um we have a great show
for you guys before we dive in i have to
give a little update on my bowl type
journey okay i watched so i was the
least productive piece of [ __ ] slob
ever yesterday i watched so much bull
type so much happened spoiler alert
they all went to paris and then richard
showed up and like it was honestly like
too much for me i was like
screaming i was just so excited i love
sutton
the characters have really started to
shift for me because i always loved
sutton
and i loved cat and i hated jane
honestly that hate is now kind of
transferring to cats she's just like so
all over the place and like she's not
really
focusing on her job she's running for
city council which is great but like
you have job to do you know you're the
director of the department you know
um but then there's a lot of you know
changes going on at scarlet like jaclyn
is like kind of being pushed out by
patrick so
there's just a lot going on and i'm like
living for it but i really i could use
so much more sutton it's disgusting in
your opinion who was like the main
character of the show
jane i felt that way in the beginning
but honestly i feel like
it's not anymore well i think that now
like the tides have turned because
everybody loves sutton so much
but i don't know why i just feel like
it's jane yeah like because i feel like
jane has like the storyline that of the
protagonist where whereas like
sutton and cat their storylines are just
written like it's not
supplementary yeah no it's a frustrating
because it should be the sutton joe
of course she needs a spin-off but i'm
happy i really uh actually like
jane and pinstripe together i think
they're cute and i just like
i know something bad is gonna go wrong
like with richard and sudden like it's
too good to be true i feel like richard
dies or something like
every time he's like on screen i'm like
oh my god thank god you're still alive
like i'm putting so many of my eggs in
richard's basket
and he just like wants to move connect
to connecticut and have a family with
sutton but like she's such a go-getting
career gal and he's gonna wait for her
so like
i don't know what's gonna go wrong but
like i know something is and i'm just
really upset about it just enjoy it
okay don't worry about it the only thing
you need to worry about with richard
because he's mr cancel your show oh
somebody dm me that the upcoming season
is the final season
it might be but like i like when it's a
final season that was planned to be the
final season i know but like a show like
the bold type is so not serious it could
just go on forever like it doesn't even
matter
but then it gets stupid and bad like
let's be intentional about the ending
and then we can like everyone gets a
happy ending
i also really like two more things about
the show the first is i like that a lot
of the like extra characters who like
were irrelevant have become
more like um prominent
prominent thank you that's the word and
you just love seeing their development
like oliver is
everything sutton's boss the second
thing i like
yeah and the second thing i like is that
i feel as though they tackle you know
difficult issues for the modern gal in a
very relatable way like
when they had that whole episode about
sutton's gun that was like so random and
out of the blue and i was like what the
[ __ ]
but i thought they made like really
interesting points about the whole thing
and it was like
it was a very interesting conversation
yeah i agree i forgot about that episode
but when i watched it i thought the same
thing like there's a whole episode about
sutton's gun
yeah betsy and then that other episode
where that girl goes viral for writing a
piece in the new yorker about like how
she was pressured into
um sex by this guy jeff and it turns out
that jeff
spoiler alert is alex from the office
the um the guy who kissed sutton in the
first season
and he wrote a rebuttal about how like
men need to do better so i just think
they really tackle like
very awkward like issues in a modern way
yeah
i would agree with that it's a great
show i'm like living for it
i'm so so glad i it's the best thing
that you ever gave me like dad asked
it's
second to your kindle wow second yeah of
course the kindle's number one
unlimited books like you could literally
read anything that's ever been written
right like i'm honestly mad at you for
giving me the bowl type because there's
only four seasons with 10 episodes
that's it's robust no 10 episodes is
nothing
it's robust no it's nothing and they're
not even full hours they're 42 minutes
because they're on cable
i think it's quite robust but that's
just me
um i caught up on the long shot with
bethany and it's called the big shot
and like again same quandaries like for
me
it's just meloxy like perry miloxier
boss miloxy is the winner
everyone that they keep bringing in is
it's not even like they're bringing in
people
who are better than the original group
they're bringing in like the people
who were eliminated from the original
group like brody the b
team but weren't you happy to see her
hire corey because he really was like a
nice
well-meaning hard-working guy but just
not fit for this role but like and now
bethany it's like
we are reminded of who bethany is where
it's like she's so tough she's so sharp
and like cutting and she'll
she'll cut you down but like she like is
so emotional
yeah she's all over the place a little
bit yeah i'm happy that
corey got the job i hope that the trial
goes well
um and in just watching the group
maloxy is the only one qualified for the
position like everyone else can go home
but i was kind of heartbroken
to see jenna go home too because it was
her first time in the bottom two nicole
has now been in the bottom two
twice so she should go home yeah of
course but nicole is like the straw that
stirs the drink and her only real
attribute for the show is starting drama
and i don't even know what we would like
talk about
but now that nicole's like on the wagon
she's not interesting like and she's
not good at the job she should be sent
home like it wasn't fair it wasn't fair
and jenna actually did a really good job
in other things and i thought the way
that she handled the photo shoot where
like everyone was having a breakdown no
one knew what to do and she was like
bethany you ready let's go
that's exactly what bethany's looking
for i just think the problem with the
show in general is that bethany has not
been clear like
at all what this particular job is
because it's a chief brand officer
but the more i'm seeing like from
bethany it's like a bethany manager
handler
job yeah i think it's like bethany's
stand-in almost like
head of the company when bethany doesn't
want to be sort of thing got it
but i agree she's looking for a mind
reader yes so far
it's like kind of like who just has the
best idea of what she wants but i just
think that miloxy is
so solid like and capable and
she's the only person who who's in the
realm
of of what bethany needs hashtag meloxy
or bust
hashtag locks here but it's like
everyone else it's it's a joke it's a tv
show
yeah i know brody's back like i'm good
no it's like the show never ends i keep
bringing people on taking people off
i think we've netted like zero yeah no
totally and it must be annoying for like
maloxie when she's like when's my
when do i where's my job interview when
do i get my crown yeah
um okay well i'm so glad that you're all
caught up i'm really loving that but
i've been focused on the bold type and i
just don't know what i'm going to do
afterwards so
that's that well we'll keep you abreast
of course we will as we always do but i
think without further ado
to do speaking of where is do i have
some errands to run so
he had to stay home it's literally doo
do
where are you no it's literally doo doo
doo doo's day and he's not even here
tuesday without further ado here are the
fast side stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
and today's episode is sponsored by the
hills new beginnings and siesta key
siesta key and the hills new beginnings
are back on mtv wednesday may 12th
starting at 8 p.m so that is tomorrow
juliette
want to know what she's up to she's
living the lavish life with sam
her billionaire boyfriend but will
kelsey reign on their parade when they
clash over their rival swimsuit brands
and this season brandon chloe madison
amanda and garrett
are trying to move forward but will
their pass pull them back under
while siesta key is embracing the
unknown the hill's new beginnings is all
about moving forward
heidi and spencer's relationship is put
to the test as they realize they're on
two different pages when it comes to
having another baby
brody and audrina are back in the dating
pool but as they start seeing other
people they begin to realize that they
may be
they may be ready to be more than just
friends justin bobby reaches out to
reconnect with his estranged family
as he looks to his past in order to
settle down and plan for his future
plus a long-awaited reunion years in the
making with a former castmate
you'll have to see to believe do you
know who it is no
do you like i think so based on the
commercials i don't know
will this hollywood crew be able to
begin again find out during the season
premieres of
siesta key and the hills new beginnings
starting wednesday may 12th
that's tomorrow at eight only on mtv
wednesday may 12th that's tomorrow
the season premiere of siesta key and
the hills new beginnings
there's so much going on in the world of
siesta key we've been waiting for the
show to come back for so long because of
the
the changing of the guards and like
julia really like
having it all and i'm so excited to
watch her she's been through so much the
last few seasons like
it's her time no and i'm obsessed with
her billy and her boyfriend like i'm
obsessed like i just want
everything coming up juliet like i and
finally for the juliet stands this is
our season i think sochi feels like
no except that juliet and kelsey are on
the outs which i do not like
no i know and i really did enjoy them as
friends but when it comes down to it
like my allegiance is always with juliet
like
i
really don't care no no my allegiance is
with julia but kelsey was a really good
friend to her
i know but until she wasn't like when
she went behind her back to like talk to
sam like that was
so [ __ ] up yeah damn okay
well first story some crazy news portia
williams is engaged
to fallon's ex simon gubatia
it took me literally 20 minutes to
figure out
what i was reading because but then when
it said fallon and i are not friends
yeah porsha confirmed on instagram that
she's engaged to simon after posting a
photo that sparked rumors of a betrothal
she said our relationship began a month
ago yes we are crazy in love i know it's
fast
but we are living life each day to its
fullest i choose happiness
every morning and every night tuning out
all the negative energy and only focused
on positive wishes he makes me so happy
and to me
that's what matters most she said that
she had nothing to do with their divorce
which they filed in january she said
fallon and i are not friends
and simon's divorce has been settled our
relationship is a positive loving step
forward in everybody's lives
no and i'm sure that's like fair i'm
sure he was divorced or whatever
but like this is just so close for
comfort
and i'm literally thinking like could
she not have found anyone else than like
a cast mate not cast mates but she was
on the show
and it seemed like they were prepping
her to be like a friend of or maybe
eventually a housewife but i don't know
now that she's not married to simon is
she like no longer interesting i don't
know or did she just become interesting
but like i think it was his money no but
like now it's porsche's fiancee's
ex-wife oh yeah by the way this is what
we need
like yes we were just recapping the
atlanta reunion yesterday just feeling
at least for me like it's just kind of
stale with this whole kenya porsche
drama
since day one they haven't met like it's
just like they haven't jived it's just
like kind of old and boring at this
point
but this now this is a real
find this is a real story yeah it's
really crazy and i liked fallon when we
met her briefly this season
i thought she was stunning yeah and she
kept her composure for the most part
when toya was saying like the most vile
things about her
yeah so between toyah fallon portia
simon i think we've got a really good
next season but this is just really
shocking i'm happy for porsha that she
found love i just [ __ ] love porsha
like nothing she could do could make me
not like her so i trust her judgment
here i'm sure there's more to the story
and i can't wait to find out
on season 13 of the real housewives of
atlanta i know but you'll be waiting a
long time i know almost as long as we
waited for siesta key i know but we
waited for cs to keep for so long but
mazel toves are in order for
porsche williams yes and mazel tov is
also in order for laverne cox who's
taking over as a host of e's red carpet
after juliana's exit
things are shaking up at e the network
announced on monday that laverne cox
will take over as host of e-signature
red carpet
coverage she will assume the role
beginning with the 2022
award season in addition to hosting live
from e the advocate actress and
emmy-winning producer will host a series
of celebrity-based interview specials
spotlighting major players in the
entertainment industry who are making
waves in hollywood
she said i'm so excited and deeply
humbled to be hosting e's iconic red
carpet coverage
for many years i would wake up early on
award show days
and i accidentally clicked on an ad
for many years i would wake up early on
award show days get my snacks in place
and watch ease coverage all day long she
said in a statement
i dreamed of walking red carpets now not
only have i had several fun and amazing
personal red carpet moments
i also get to be a red carpet guide for
ease discerning audience and chat with
my colleagues and folks i deeply admire
for these very special events in their
lives i can't wait to get started while
hopefully serving up
fashion fantasies for the ages honey
okay i have so many thoughts
my first thought is that i love this
selection i think that like these
jobs are so iconic in entertainment
history you think of joan rivers you
think of giuliana rancic
and so i think for it to be laverne cox
who is a trans woman of color is like
everything of the sort i do feel like
laverne cox is like a little too famous
for this job that's like
jennifer aniston taking the job but like
she's talent my question is like
yeah she's the one that's usually
walking the carpet is she gonna
interview herself
so it does feel like in a lot of ways
this like might be like a step down for
her
not in fame but just in like in like the
work like it's a
she could just walk like and now when
there's an award so she used to just
like show up and like have a great time
and now she's like working
the show yeah i feel like it would be
more preferable to just like
sail down the red carpet no and like
keep winning emmys like she's an actress
by trade yeah now the other thing is
that like you know
there are so much that goes into being
an interviewer you know
and i think it's actually a lot harder
than a lot of people think and most
people who have
found success in in like a giuliana
ranch have been interviewing people for
years and years and years
so i hope i imagine there'll be some
sort of
um like learning curve with laverne
because you have to retain so much
information like he puts together these
binders
you have to know everything about
everyone and it's just it's not just
talking like it's
yeah it's a real skill yes it's it's
like the practice of it plus that x
factor talent like can you talk to
people
but it is also like the studying
memorizing the
producer in your ear like having your
next question ready like it's also
a job right and those jobs they're so
rare when they come up they usually go
to like the next person in line waiting
who's been doing it for years
and that's not laverne so i'm just i'm
very curious to see how we start i know
she'll be great but yeah it'll be
interesting
it will be interesting but we also won't
see it until 2022 and like i
just that's in so long and also i don't
know if this is a story today but
there's like awards drama
there's awards drama because nbc will no
longer be airing the golden globes i
like feel that
i feel it too like i hope this is a
trend no i think
it might when i saw it i'm like oh this
is we've been talking about it for years
how award shows are so like out of touch
and outdated and they're on cable like
gen z doesn't watch award shows like
nobody [ __ ] cares
so i think that this might be like the
initial descent
into whatever the next phase of award
shows is because they just feel so
outdated
yeah or just another network will pick
up the golden globes and it will just be
i i really don't hope so i really i
really don't hope so i hope everyone's
like yeah
well can you imagine nbc like on a prime
sunday giving up three hours of their
telecast for five people to tune in
no i think that's such that's just bad
business yeah but it's not about the
shitty numbers which it really should be
it's about controversy within the hfpa
what's the controversy um that there's a
lack of diversity within the members of
the foreign
hollywood heart foreign press
association
and other um like statements of
controversy and stuff like interesting
yeah so
not about the ratings but like i said
award shows are just
kind of not like so out of touch you
know who should host the award shows
elon musk he should host everything is
this a piece of ice in my mouth or
strawberry
i can't see ice okay good i'm like i'm
drinking this strawberry refresher
and it's good but like these
strawberries i don't like live fruit in
my
i don't like fruits period oh i agree
i've had to like live fruit
due to um my pritikin eating plants
what's dead fruit
dead fruit i guess dried oh yeah you
know but um
i like fruit flavored like for example i
just had a blueberry yogurt and this
brand did not put
blueberries did you see my finger that's
the sugar from your drink oh my god did
you see that
that's the sugar i'm tremoring oh my god
i cannot
this whole journey with the starbucks is
like really [ __ ] me up that was
weird yeah oh my god i did not like that
um what was i saying fruit not myself
oh fruit so some yogurts like they put
fruit in like fruit pieces in the yogurt
and like people really like that that's
disgusting i think it's so twisted soggy
i can stomach a blueberry in the
blueberry favorite yogurt but a
strawberry
sick no also that's like um those
fruit bars like uh popsicles that have
real fruit in them like
i'm not picking up an ice cream bar for
real fruit sick
sick and twisted yeah are you ready for
our next story little podcast news
i'm always wait is it the podcast news
it's brought to you by hair food
yes it is wow that's crazy hair food
offers simple superfood inspired
products that will make your hair look
and feel amazing
whatever hair texture or hair type you
have hair food has a recipe for you
in addition to their beloved nourishing
coconut milk and chai spice collection
you've got to try some of their new
recipes they have the apple cider
vinegar hair rings apple cider vinegar
vinegar is so
good for your hair and their product is
perfect for days when your hair needs a
gentle cleanse before conditioning
there is no shampoo needed they also
have a turmeric and almond oil
detangling mix
because detangler's just not only for
children like adults get detanglers too
and this product takes care of most the
most stubborn knots and it reduces frizz
they also have a shea butter and pear
color repair concentrate it makes
over-processed hair look vibrant and
healthy and they smell
so good every product is free of
sulfates parabens dyes mineral oils
and is certified by peta as cruelty free
so it's never too late to start taking
care of your hair the apple cider
vinegar um
rinse is everything of the sort all
their products are made so well they
smell good they feel good and you will
see a visible difference
in the texture and the feel of your hair
so if you're looking for a nourished
healthy hair it's got to be hair food
look for it at amazon walmart and target
that's hair food
sold at amazon walmart and target also
pronounced target
love it okay welcome to the podcast
industry
dave chappelle yes i saw his new podcast
dropped at 1201 a.m
on tuesday called midnight miracle the
comic hinted on social media that the
podcast is coming out may 11th
but we hear more specifically it'll be
available tuesday one minute after the
clock strikes midnight so that would
have been
like 10 hours ago um the luminary
podcast from chappelle
talib kweli and yasin bay was recorded
during chappelle's 2020 summer camp
in his hometown of yellow springs ohio
the venue where it was recorded was
dubbed the shack a mechanic's garage
retrofitted as a clubhouse that's fine
so this is very exciting news for the
podcast
it's huge i mean the king of comedy and
stand up is
entering our little you know industry
like so exciting so excited i think this
was a great idea
for luminary or whoever it's a great get
for them dave chappelle is like a
cultural icon and honestly there's so
much going on in the world and you never
really hear from dave chappelle but he's
so smart and i always like when things
are going on i'm like what would dave
chappelle say about this
and i think this podcast is hopefully
moving forward going to be that just
that so
i'm i think this is great for a
multitude of reasons it's great for the
industry it's great for the consumer
and she's fabulous yes competition
rewards the consumer this is great
it's just really surprising i don't know
why i'm so surprised because i really
he's so talented like he
he does not need to serve up episodes
once a week yeah here he is about to do
it it's surprising because
dave chappelle's whole image is like
this air of mystery like he doesn't
really have a social media he does shows
every now and then and they're always
kind of underground he's very low-key
living in ohio so
his whole brand is like you can't never
find me you don't know where i
am but a podcast is very here's where i
am it's very
exposure yeah which i think is it's
great
um but you're right it does seem like an
off-brand thing to do but
podcasting for the most part is
mostly comedy like there's every
comedian has a podcast
they kind of go hand in hand like when
you say comedian and podcaster that's
like one job
you think so i feel like not for the
icons like
no nothing but for like the people on
their way up and the people on their way
down
yeah the top i don't know if i'm on my
way up or down
i think it depends on the day for us 100
percent after the miley thing yesterday
i'm like so relevant
i'm so relevant like the gentleman toast
to the moon
they didn't even know who i was and now
they do like can you talk about a
successful
pr stunt yeah toast to the moon baby
yeah no you're right but it just it is a
natural thing for
people who are funny podcasts that's
like a natural next step whether
you're huge or not so it does make sense
i'm just like surprised
in a good way in a great way can't wait
to listen can't wait to listen
have you been listening to the jamae
podcast no i've listened to some of it
um but i didn't listen to all of it so
if you guys don't know chris lilly who
is an australian comedian who wrote
summer heights high
chris uh jamae private school girl jonah
from tonga
he's super funny he has all these
different characters and he has a
podcast now as one of his most
successful characters
who is jamae private school girl she's
like this really [ __ ] high school
australian teenager and the podcast was
i listened to the first episode only i
need to like catch up
i loved it like it was just so
stellar and it was hysterical and i miss
jamae
all the time miss jamae all the time no
i don't listen to that many podcasts
because we're constantly podcasting
there's not that much time left and if
i'm ever working out
i listen to music like but yesterday i
got my eyelashes
tinted that's a great time for me to
listen to podcasts and the one podcast
that i like so much
that i'm always telling you is so funny
yeah is sofia with an f yeah
i feel like you guys have similar sense
of humor she's just so
so funny and so whenever i get a chance
to listen to a podcast i usually go with
hers
or joe rogan depending on the guest the
guest by the way dave chappelle was just
on joe rogan
but for me uh like if a podcast has a
video component i'm watching the video
i'm not listening as a podcast so
his video only plays in the spotify app
on your phone and if you close it
no but like i want to watch it on my tv
because if i'm watching a video i don't
want to watch on my phone i want to
watch on my tv but you can't watch the
podcast video
on the spotify app on your tv so it has
to be a really specific instance so i
have to like really go out of my way to
be like i'm going to sit down in front
of my phone for three no you can airplay
it you have apple tv you just airplay
your phone
airplay spotify app yeah tv no just like
screen mirroring your phone to the apple
tv
oh my gosh call me tim cook baby no call
me tim cook i give you the idea
that's actually a really good idea yeah
that is a good idea so yeah i really
like joe rogan and sophia with an f
oh my god by the way i will definitely
when i have some time listen to dave
chappelle on joe rogan that probably
sounds fabulous
yep do you ever listen to other podcasts
um no
but i did uh listen to a few episodes i
think it's called hey babe with
chris destefano from guy code he hosts a
podcast with sal
from impractical jokers i think no no
sorry no no by the way everyone's gonna
laugh
that's not i wish i didn't say that like
i actually want to die sorry
that's not who it is that's not who it
is hold on just like oh my god i'm sober
oh no sal sal and chris
sal vulcano is he from yeah he's from
okay is he from impractical jokers i
don't know
let me just look it up salvagano a
comedian yeah okay okay okay
he's okay oh my god i feel so much
better and they had this sound go
viral on tick tock because they put
clips of their podcast up on tick tock
and it was so funny
chris stefano was talking about how he's
like packing something up in tupperware
and he calls it tubberware and sal was
like
go back what did you just say and he's
like tupperware
tupperware and he's like tupperware and
he's and he realized his whole life he's
been saying tubberware instead of
tupperware and that's what got me into
the podcast this is a very long-answered
question so i listened to a little bit
of that podcast but i really don't
this besides tnn i don't really listen
to
a ton of other podcasts it's just based
on the guests because between all the
time we spend recording podcasts and
listening to
editing in our wheelhouse like that's
just all the podcast
time you've got 100 but uh lauren has a
new episode out i think
from last week that i haven't listened
to yet with like a millennial dating
coach which i
am married but i think i need to listen
to yeah i want to know like what the
millennials need to know about dating
like what's the latest and greatest i
have no idea because i'm always giving
dating advice to people but i'm not sure
if it's outdated
100 it is you're literally the most like
traditional person um and i'm always
giving dating advice to people when i
have absolutely no right to be seeing as
how i've been on one date in my life but
you could argue that you're so good at
dating that all it took was one date for
you and all of a sudden snatched up
married
you could argue that but you would be
wrong why because it was just
you didn't look so good like but i did
it and it was like messy
and like honestly it was just like the
universe really helping me out you know
you think finding ben on like day one
that was just like a huge win from god
i don't think it could have been anyone
on that date and you just would have
like knocked it out of the parking
garage
no i don't think so either honestly yeah
but um
it's a fun fact about you yeah it's my
you have a
perfect dating record one for one
hundred percent
one for one okay ready for our next
story it's a little fashion news
um it's the fashion well as a maxine
instead myself
um i'm ready no you're gonna be excited
about this because house of harlow
nicole ritchie's brand
just launched a collab with sophia
richie they're finally collabing
for their first ever collaboration the
ritchie sisters co-designed the spring
collection for nicole's fashion and
lifestyle brand house of harlow
the line available exclusively at
revolve i didn't know that that was
exclusive
i did because it's the only place i i
wear a lot of house of harlow it's very
size inclusive
and i have only seen an arm revolve and
that's where i get it i didn't know that
that was like a decision that was made
no it's smart coincidence offers pieces
that reflect nicole's signature 70s
bohemian aesthetic and effortlessly cool
designs inspired
by sophia's personal style like two of
the most stylish gals
on earth but very different aesthetics
yes like
sophia is very like gen z like like
modern instagram modern and nicole
has maintained this like flowy bow
that's why i like it all the clothes are
flowy
boho you know gold jewelry vibe bengals
since she started the brand so i'm
interested to see what the final product
is going to be yes nicole said from the
beginning of house of harlow i imagined
it a place where my family would come
and create if they ever felt a desire to
sophia has an incredibly unique cool and
effortless sense of style
and it felt natural to incorporate that
feel into the spring collection
this is one of those things that now
that it's happened i'm like how did this
happen
how did this not happen sooner i'm so
excited to check it out yeah me too
um speaking of nicole richie not to make
it about you no
i i think that we should make it about
me so tell us what happened to you
so i know you guys know i've been doing
this coffee review and i've told you
guys yesterday how i meant for it to
blow
up on tick tock which it hasn't yet but
i'll get there um but it's really blown
up on my reels like almost all of them
have been like hitting a million views
which is really great
um and it's you know kind of attracting
a lot of celebrity
viewers one of them being nicole richie
who asked me to
try her beverage which was a plain black
hot coffee
which i did try this morning the video
is going to be over she says it
you'll drink it of course nicole [ __ ]
you could literally tell me to eat duty
pureed with a splash of milk and i'd be
like yum this is delicious i love milk
i love milk and duty um
yeah i know i just like thought of duty
in a blender stop stop and then like
splash
[ __ ] so that video will be up like a
little bit later but yeah i don't know
i might be getting too famous for the
show oh okay you might have to start
fighting my replacement
okay we should host a show like the big
shot
with jackie oh that would actually be
like a really cool
funny yeah when you like try out
different people for a host and like the
different activities are like
reading from a teleprompter reading ad
copy no but like
or like we are vlogging together like
just like some really fun stuff that's a
good idea
such a great idea are you ready for the
final story a little biz news merger
news
okay but it sounds like since the fifth
and final story is a little biz news
you do not have the beverly hills
taglines as a story today
no i don't you're right i just go
through them really quickly i feel like
that's what people want to talk about no
you're
so right i'm so rdh that's okay
and i'm so sorry about that and i have a
lot to say about
all of them because i was like a little
uninspired by all of them me too
okay here we go kyle richards this town
is a game of chess
but no one's taking this queen down it's
fine it's very kyle richards
for me it's perfection 10 out of 10 hits
every point like
homage references old taglines
references old story line
my friends with you is like playing
chess with bobby fischer yeah like
in this town da-da-da yeah no it's so
kyle if
it's not a kyle tagline if it doesn't
reference the town right i would have
maybe like to see her reference like
family because her sister's coming on
but
it's fine oh that's true i didn't think
about that still i'm getting into ten
animations
that's a direct threat to kathy actually
i'm gonna give it five out of five
because i think like there should be
five criteria and she hits them all okay
five out of five
lisa rinna oh zero out of five i hated
this my lips are legendary and they will
never gloss over the truth
i'll give it a two yeah it's just like
so played out at this point
and honestly for the past few seasons
you actually have glossed over the truth
because you like didn't want to be like
the big
dramas queen anymore she made a
conscious decision to kind of pull that
back in so it's not entirely factually
active unless she's like not
glossing over the truth when it comes to
erica we'll see well we shall see
garcelle if you want a starring role in
my life you better drop the act
that's pretty cool like i'm gonna give
it a four it's a nice play on words i'm
gonna give it a three i just
really liked hers last season life's an
audition and honey
i am getting that part yeah it was just
great
um so this is like a little bit of a
step down for me to read this one hurts
yeah dress like there's no tomorrow and
then tomorrow
do it again so i would have given this a
four if i hadn't
given derit the most perfect tagline on
a silver platter and i'm just in the
comments section i'm just gonna assume
and i know that she saw it because she
then used it as a caption i'm gonna
assume that they had already recorded
their taglines and it was too late
because
mine was i may not always be on time but
i'm always on point
no it's really good because she's always
late and she always looks amazing this
three one like
honestly i think you're giving like way
too high scores this is also like a
three out of five they're not bad but
they're just not
great they're yeah they're not great
sutton anyone who doubts my exquisite
manners can kiss my exquisite derriere
okay i didn't like the way she
pronounced derriere in the thing it's
like derriere
and i don't know i just like didn't like
it either like i like the homage to her
southern roots i just think it could
have been worded more playfully it
doesn't sound right
more playfully and like more eloquently
yeah it sounds weird
i agree and also like if she's talking
about her manners she's also talking
about her derriere it's like a little
oxymoron hello yeah yeah pot you're the
kettle up
crystal yeah oh crystal yes hollywood is
full of pretenders
and i slay them all
what's with the sleigh like is that an
is her husband like
i'm trying to think there's a reference
there i don't know i feel like we have
to see the
the season to know like are people
pretending around
in the season because that sucks and is
she slaying them that sucks
okay but maybe if i understand yeah no
so without contact maybe they own a
sleigh company like i don't know i'm
trying to figure it out
fifth i'm sorry that's not the fifth
fifth and final story
erica jane oh the strongest substance on
earth
isn't diamonds it's me okay i also have
to give that like a one out of five what
does that even mean
and i like the message because she it
it's gonna be a difficult season for her
and she is very mentally tough and
strong and she will get through it
message of erica jane is strong i
execution
i approve this message but execution
zero it stinks
like and and the thing is is that
beverly hills
it's the crown jewel like and they the
editing the outfits the trips
the teasers like it's always top tier
and this was like for me it's okay i
would say overall the taglines get a
three out of five
yeah i agree um also whenever we talk
about tag lines now i don't know why
like you know what tagline is living in
my head
rent-free which i may be cut from a
different cloth
but it's top quality fabric every time i
hear that on
housewives i cringe a little i literally
chuckle every single time speaking of
new jersey is on tonight
can't wait um no there's so many like
ones that live completely rent-free in
my mind and a lot of them are from
beverly hills because they really set
the standard i fought too hard for this
zip code to go home now
that is the most desperate time of all
time
i'm an enigma wrapped in a riddle and
cash
and that was such a strong this year i'm
an enigma
wrapped in a riddle with no cash legal
bills
no i'm an enigma wrapped in a riddle and
i need
cash so sad
um no i mean i feel like erica is gonna
be fine going to be fine i feel like the
the buzz around it is probably bigger
than like what she's probably gonna go
through yeah but i
i feel like she is really stronger than
diamonds
no she's i feel like she really is the
strongest substance in the world
something she's just putting together
like a science equation you know
does this work science fair justice for
the science fair maybe uh that'll be one
of her storylines she's entering in the
science fair
what the strongest substance in the
world is it's just like really literal
you know and then jackie gold tonight
is also and she shows up and she's like
you might have the strongest substance
in the world
but i've got the top quality fabric
[Music]
why does someone make me laugh
so hard because it's also the way that
she says it like you can hear she's like
smiling as she's recording it because
she's so proud of herself
and it's top quality fabric
it's honestly so lame it's so
lame lemay like no they're all so bad
also ever since we did a deep dive on
freedom never tasted so good what oh
theresa yeah by the way if you guys are
interested in this conversation we
actually did
a little while ago on the patreon i'd
like deep dive on housewives tagline
housewives tagline of all time we did
two episodes
over a hundred minutes of us talking
about housewives taglines
dissecting the person the tagline their
journey
yeah their family remember lynn from oc
like there's just so many you forget
about
yeah so if you want this conversation to
go into the archives
patreon.com the morning toast it's also
just a great way to support the toast
always are you ready for a fifth and
final the little biz news that's brought
to you by betterhelp
yep is there something interfering with
your happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals
better help will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist
so for me like some of those things that
are interfering with my personal life
goals
are anxiety seasonal depression
and those are all things that can be
helped with better help where you can
start communicating in under 48 hours
better help is not a crisis line and
it's not self-help it is professional
counseling
done very securely online there's a
broad range of expertise available which
may not be locally available in many
areas
their service is available for clients
worldwide you can log into your account
anytime and send a message to your
counselor
you'll get timely and thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule weekly
video or phone sessions
so you won't ever have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room as with
traditional therapy
betterhelp is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they make
it easy and free to change counselors if
need about if needed
it's also more affordable than
traditional offline counseling and
financial aid is available
betterhelp wants you to start living a
happier life today
visit betterhelp.com toast that's better
h-e-l-p
and join the over 1 million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional
in fact so many people have been using
better that they are recruiting
additional counselors in all 50 states
today's episode is sponsored by
betterhelp and the morning toast
listeners
get 10 off their first month at
betterhelp.com
toast love it ok the final story
it's a little buzz news it's a little
mergers and acquisitions who's merging
and acquiring barnes and noble
owner is buying stationy stationary
retailer paper source
out of bankruptcy not papyrus oh that's
what i was going to do tyrus's cousin
paper source papyrus's cousin paper
source is papyrus still in business
i feel like we've reported like in our
old studio looking good like
i haven't seen one that's up in adam in
a while
i mean i talked about since paper source
is so similar to papyrus like obviously
papyrus holds a special place in my
heart but i just need to make sure that
there is
a there can only be one i think it
should have been papyrus but elliott
investment management the owner of
barnes and noble
the owner of toaster strudel said
tuesday it will acquire
gift and stationary retailer paper
source the acquisition will provide
paper source with the funding it needs
to emerge
from chapter 11 bankruptcy well talk
about a tough business to be in selling
books and stationery via retail
i mean this guy just has a death wish
like it's he must be the most stressed
man
you know he's definitely the least
stressed man in america because if he's
working in a barnes noble
then he has a definite sense of calm and
i think with this move to buy paper
source shows that he's like a man of
taste like i'm sure that this man is
actually
the most common man in america no that's
fair i hope that the barnes noble
corporate office emulates the same kind
of vibes that the barnes and noble
retail stores do because
as a published author myself who has
spent many time in the last couple
months and barnes and noble's where my
book is available girl with no job the
crazy beautiful life of an instagram
thirst monster
i can really speak to how peaceful they
are yeah
so i'm here for this like we need
stationery stores they're so beautiful
stunning and smart and like the
pinterest bombs like they need it like
there's a real community of people
there there really is and i would just
be sad if all of them
went out i mean hopefully someone can
rescue papyrus i hope it's not too late
honestly like jeff bezos should buy it
like just throw us a bone here i think
you're freaking bone here i totally
agree like just do it
just do it no he's gonna start popping
up amazon stationery stores like
how they put so many barnes and nobles
out of business and then like
slapped in the face with an amazon
bookstore yeah but like
amazon stationery would never have the
heart and soul of papyrus no matter how
many how much how hard he tried no
matter how many chanel bags you have
you borrow you will never be a lady
that's such a good point i'm so glad you
brought that up
i just feel like every now and then i
remember that i'm a new york times
bestselling author and it's just like a
nice feeling you know i feel like you
don't talk about it enough
and you guys probably think i talk about
it so much but i don't know i just feel
like i wanted to mention it again today
i don't know if you guys know him
we might have someone watching for the
first time maybe a miley stan
and when you are calling her shrek
and a fat that you should also add
new york times best selling shrek that
new york best
new york times best-selling fat track
okay and i will be referred to as
nothing else don't get it twisted
honestly you know what justice for shrek
total he was a nice boy he was so nice
thoughtful landowner paid his
own rent and minded his own business
didn't need help from anyone didn't have
rich parents who owned another local
swamp
no he took that swamp all on his own and
he took that annoying ass donkey
under his wing he rescued animals
protected him he cared about our furry
friends
what more could you want out of a man
and he loved fiona no matter what she
looked like at the night in the day with
the green skin you know he didn't care
he didn't care love is blind that's what
trex said shrek was blind
[Laughter]
um yeah no i'm just like done with like
shrek being like the punching bag for
fat people you know
no i think shark is a compliment i think
he's a wonderful man he has
layers and you know what like he is
cutie
major cutie chubby chaser no and it's
like what i'm supposed to want
lord farquaad no yeah like this short
uh egotistic karen haircut
we had the karen haircut yeah wants to
talk to the manager always
no like please like let's stop using
shrek
stop shaming shrek let's stop using
shrek as a projection of our fat phobic
rhetoric
well you know what here's it from a
different angle what if that miley stand
feels the same way about trek
and it was a compliment and it was a
compliment look how negative we are just
assuming it was a negative
landowner who loves her furry friends oh
my god that is me even though i rent
you know what i mean yeah for sure um
that is our show
correct that's our show it's nobody
else's people might try and say
i don't know one person who would
wouldn't want to be associated with this
they might say like no that was my show
no it's our show
thank you so much for listening to the
morning shows the millennial morning
show where we deliver the best five
stories that you need to know every
morning before you wake up in the
morning
wait what before you wake up and take a
bite of your morning toast um you can
i just [ __ ] the whole thing up
basically just go leave a podcast review
the miley stands
attacked our reviews and are probably
writing mean things about fat trek so
if you're a real toaster can you just
write a review because like they're
going to try and take us down things
yeah that would be
actually really kind of you and you
could also watch this on youtube and
airplay it to your tv
yes i don't know if you guys knew that
have a great day everyone we'll see you
tomorrow for
hump day hump day friday
oh no good luck sorry bye